yeah we've got to ask what did his
favorite favorite anime was he's just
like yeah yeah he's just like a romance
anime he loves like dramatic romance so
like i like rom-coms yeah and he likes
the
the romance anime that like golden time
i like golden time
is it like super dramatic and like
[ __ ] up stuff happening yes and he
probably likes it yeah but like he i
can't figure out what danis likes
because he'll tell me he likes one thing
and then he'll tell me some other stuff
and i'm like these are like completely
coral
like i cannot figure out they're like oh
this is [ __ ] i'm like what that's like
universally praised i mean he said he's
his favorite is clannad
he likes the drama
right so like you'll notice that if you
ask him what his favorite character is
in like every show he always picks the
ones that everyone hates not because
he's trying to be a contrarian but he
just loves the characters that cause
problems i don't know like me and me and
dardis have exactly the same taste with
like romance and he loves [ __ ] trashy
romance and like this is the spice he
loves ichigo 100 that should tell you
more than enough
okay okay okay
like just from that you know exactly
yes exactly yeah like messy drama he
loves what is it nana yeah
that's good though that's a good mama's
a good choice i remember i remember when
i was a kid and i was trying to read
nana i was like what that was happening
i'm too young for this
yeah it's definitely a mature show it's
definitely like
it definitely ain't a slice of life
comedy that's that's for sure i mean
it's kind of a slice of life but it's
like he loves things that i feel like
normal people would find soul crushing
um
yes
i like that as well i like those yeah
yeah i like the depressing shows yeah
that's like magical right
it's depressing but they're like oh
pretty colors yeah i certainly didn't
look at madoka magicker and go oh
magical
i was like oh what happened to madoka
magica did you just fall off
what do you mean did it end it ended it
ended really like years ago i watched
some guy i watched like the movies and
i'm gonna be honest i don't know what
the [ __ ] happened no dude i don't
understand the moment
i was i was
and that's when i was like what what
happened i i watched the movies i didn't
know what happened yeah i don't i didn't
i don't even think the creator of madoka
magicka knows what happens okay because
for years i was so scared to say that
i'd watch the movie just in case people
ask me what happened yeah and i'd be
like
no but you're okay because literally
everyone who watched the movie
i didn't know this because no one talks
about maybe everyone's the same thing as
me but like i don't want to pretend like
i'm the i don't want to be the only one
but do you remember what happened at the
end of madoka magicka
no
you had to know what happened in the
movie you have to bear in mind it's been
like 2014. yeah don't remember that yeah
yeah but that's because the the ten
episodes leading up to i'll be honest
like what the [ __ ] i watched all of my
durka but i can literally only remember
like the one scene where like mammy dies
oh yeah i mean that's that's the
spoilers by the way
if you don't [ __ ] know that by now
you come on you should have watched
madoka magic yeah that's the scene that
just got like memed the [ __ ] up and
that's what like made madoka explode but
yeah like there was technically a sequel
movie and everyone tries to forget that
it exists um
it's i don't know why i don't even
remember it was bad yeah it was it was
it was [ __ ] i'll just say it's [ __ ] i'll
go i'll go on and i'll say [ __ ] i'm sure
there's like 10 madoka fans that are
like no it was a masterpiece
yeah i mean i i watched it and it's like
it kind of like gave a plot twist and
then just ended and then uh they just
never came how do you remember this [ __ ]
i i literally for the life of me cannot
keep recall or like keep memories of
shows that i just were like huh well
then i just feel like
that just means they were me
yeah i mean it wasn't even mid it was so
bad that i immediately no but it was it
was horrible you'd remember it wasn't
that horrible so it was confusing no no
it was still like a two out of ten like
horrible for me it's like zero out of
ten right or like hilariously zero out
of ten yeah like the like the room right
you can't yeah yeah yeah that's like
stays with you yeah but it's like it's
like someone had a vision and they
should have been stopped like
you know what i mean like yeah
i mean i mean like the madoka movie was
just really confusing that was pretty
much it i felt like that's 90 of anime
movies though
no no a lot of movies i i watched at
least when i started watching anime i
was like what the [ __ ] you mean anime
films based off tv shows like the ones
that continued or the ones that had like
parts that weren't like pokemon they
were very easy to follow
like what uh what's some other 2000s
shows that had movie spin-offs or movie
like sequel prequel things
or metal alchemist that
yeah that was the circus one right where
they went to the circus in the start
right that's all i remember and then
they went to the tower and there was a
dragon in the tower i remember that and
i don't even remember that i don't
remember anything else black butler no
no wait full metal alchemist yeah there
was like a tower there was a dragon in
the tower wait okay how did you feel
about the black bottle movie
uh
oh the the book of atlantic yeah no i
mean that's like literally just like
covering a really simple part of the
plot where they're like there's like
zombies on a boat yeah i'm trying to
think of confusing anime movies and the
only one that comes to mind is
evangelion yeah
okay there that one i haven't watched
that because i heard that was confusing
madoka was one of them uh
on the same level was like in the end of
ava where it's just like i don't know
what i i maybe i'm completely talking
out my ass actually i i just got like
research
this is a common occurrence on trash
taste i'm sorry
i do remember that we have to like talk
about him realizing that he's full of
[ __ ] that's true that's true
i shouldn't just make broad
broad statements that make no sense what
is my state where is my source i made it
the [ __ ] up
it's like every anime movie is confusing
did you watch could you repeat that
higurashi
yeah
the one though
like they had like the season one right
yeah and then they had season two which
came out after it right yeah and then
the newest one was a remake yes now it's
a reimagining
see i hate how they do that i hate when
they do that wait so it's not even the
same it's like the same show but it's
like a different timeline i don't know
supposedly i didn't finish it like the
ava movies yeah right i don't know
anyone who watched season two of
higarashi except like joey i did yeah
but joe doesn't care because i know a
lot of people who watch season two
russia really i i could not see this was
good because if you're not gonna
understand it unless you watch season
two so so i watched season one yeah but
i watched it in english yeah and that
was a big mistake yeah because then i
went to watch season two which only had
japanese dub and it was such whiplash
for me at the time when i was like
you have to get used to the voices it
was like because the the english version
of higurashi is notoriously very bad it
is awful
it was such because obviously they it
was so different yeah like that even
like the how the overall vibe of the
show right was so different because the
dub was so mid yeah there you go
it was it wasn't it really wasn't it
really wasn't good so like going to the
japanese one was just like yeah the
whiplash was too strong and i couldn't
like get past the first episode yeah oh
wow but also i'll be honest i didn't
really know the fact was going on i
don't really know why
well because i pay attention but season
two literally explains everything that
happens yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so so
lit literally just explain [ __ ] as we're
going you know because that's the
fingernail or being one or is that still
yeah that's season one yeah yeah so
basically it's like season one is set up
so that it's kind of this like mystery
plot line is it really good it's it's
actually really good i should go back
and watch [ __ ] all right i would
recommend it like so like the the way
that the game was originally set up was
that like you go through this like
storyline with multiple play throughs
but they don't give you all the
information
and then season two of the anime is like
oh well you've tried to figure out the
riddle here's the answer then they
explain everything that happens and then
you're like oh that totally makes sense
yeah so you literally just got this you
watch the season where you you have
every question and nothing's answered
you basically look you basically looked
at the riddle and went well there's no
answer all right
maybe the group's i was in no one
watched it but i don't know yeah yeah
probably a bunch of other monkey okay
and then don't bother after season three
like it sucks well i heard the remake
because i know you might like it because
it's just the slice of life of all the
characters like yeah it's just like
hanging without like the creepy myths
right what yeah
that was like seasonal what's the [ __ ]
part of the appeal though that's that
one they made like people like emily
i don't want to see them killing each
other
i just want to see them going to the
pool and hanging out
they're just such cute little girls
i just want to see
i liked it a lot back when i was in
middle school yeah but i feel like when
you're in middle school you're kind of
more of like a little little edge lord
yeah of course yeah you watch anything
when you're in school i don't think i
would like it now if i watched it again
no i mean the only reason i watched it
was because i'm like yo these cute girls
are [ __ ] each other oh
no
get on
like do you ever think about
like how anime starved you were when you
were a kid so like you would just
consume anything and sometimes you're
just kind of welcome to my life you had
no you had no business being a 12 year
old reading this stuff but you kept
going yeah when you like watched like
when you were like yo anime's for adults
let me put on the first episode of elf
and leaves well that [ __ ] freaked me out
when i was like 13. man did you watch
that
yeah when i was i i think i watched like
two episodes and i was like dude
literally the opening scene is a severed
arm and i was like goated
i was like no i can't do it too much
it just felt like it was gory for the
sake of no no
it completely was because it was
completely aimed for kids but i just
like remember like so many [ __ ] 13.
yeah yeah i just remember like so many
[ __ ] you know that image where she's
like animes for kids what's this then
it was like elephant league it was it
was the first episode of elephant i'm
just like
it's it's the most one of the most
immature anime to come out but
you know
we it was framed as an adult anime but
it was definitely dude when you were 14
you ate that [ __ ] this is literally like
i'm 13 and this is deep
you watched katana
no that's one of my favorites that's
fantastic yeah [ __ ] no one's watched
that goddamn show i know i'm so sad it's
so good have you watched it gone uh i
haven't actually it's the one of the
only wow it's one of the most underrated
initiations yeah it's so goddamn good
that's one of my favorite anime of all
time oh really yeah hell yeah
yeah what are some of your other
favorites
i don't know what we haven't talked
about so we've established card captor
sakura fruits basket clan ad yeah good
taste
like connoisseur
oh that's good
who doesn't like it i love connoisseurs
yeah do you like uh michelle
did you watch it nope why not
what is it jobless reincarnation is the
english title what is going on
is the one who brought up richard
potency it's like i just thought because
like kind of subah
maybe you might like chocolatenzo maybe
is definitely more light-hearted than
meshuggah tensei i don't know do you
recommend do you recommend it do i add
it to my watchlist yeah he's like
that's like saying like yeah
sakamotodeska is a lot like log horizon
because they both wear glasses it is
actually because he's always very good
at whatever he does
that's the anime you gotta watch you
gotta watch sakamoto that's amazing one
that's actually a banger you love that
that's like yeah
is that the guy who's just like oh my
god i would like that you would love
them